في بيان له اعلن الجيش السوداني تعرض
طائره اجلاء تركيا من طراز 130 الى اطلاق
نار من قبل من وصفهم بالمتمردين اثناء
استعدادها للهبوط بمطار وادي سيدنا وقال
الجيش السوداني ان خزانات الوقود
بالطائرات او بالطائره تضررت كما اصيب احد
افراد طاقمها لكنها هبطت بسلام وتخضع
حاليا لاعمال اصلاح ويحضر الجيش السوداني
من من وصفهم بالمتمردين من محاولات عرقله
جهود الاجلاء كما اعلن الجيش السوداني ان
من سماهم المتمردين هاجموا موقعا له بجبل
اولياء وتصدى لهم وكبدهم خسائر كبيره
ان جاتها نقدت قوات الدعم السريع ما قالها
الجيش السوداني عن مهاجمتها طائره تركيه
في سماء وادي سيدنا في ام درمان وانفت
وجود اي قوات لها في المنطقه كما كانت
قوات الدعم السريع ما وصفتها بالقيادات
الانقلابيه داخل الجيش وفنون النظام
البائد
وقالت قوات الدعم السريع ان الجيش هاجم
مواقع تمركز الدعم السريع في قاعده جبل
اولياء وام درمان ما تسبب في عقه تحرك
البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي تعمل على اجراء
رعاياها واضافت ان هذه الخروقات للهدنه
الانسانيه تثبت بشكل واضح تعدد مراكز
اتخاذ القرار داخل الجيش